hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round six of the super
bet chess classic it's a game between
levon arunan and alexander grishok
and it's a game that will most
definitely improve your sunday it
doesn't matter how good of a sunday you
were having uh once you see this this is
a true masterpiece
uh as the title suggests this hollow one
plays he just um
okay sometimes he he has a bad game like
in the previous one where he played that
one move and he lost the game to mommy
uh but this game is just uh incredible
by
played by both of them both of them
played an incredible game
and uh well it's similar with most
incredible games that
the best parts of the game are never
actually seen on the board so that's why
we like to analyze games and especially
when we analyze classical games and this
is a classical game
we see all the wonders that we might
miss
over the course of the actual game so
without further ado let's check it out
and
enjoy this uh well uh i i i i i'm uh out
of lack for words
i i would say brilliancy but you'll see
what i mean so the one with the white
pieces
opens with d4 and it's not going to be a
fancy opening or anything just a
very normal stuff that we usually see c4
e6 knights to see
knight to f3 and d5 so just uh the usual
queen's gambit declined
knight to c3 and now d5 the semitarash
is on the board with e3
and now knight to c6 we have a3
and now d captures in c4 here you could
play d captures in c4c captures on d4
are very popular moves a6 by far the
most popular move in the position
but okay here we have d captures in c4
black ones white to play bishop captures
on c4
and then use this bishop on c4 to
further expand on the queen side here
so bishop captures and only now a6
preparing to play b5 with tempo attack
the bishop and then develop this bishop
to b7
we have castles pilot one and now uh
sasha goes
b5 so pushing the bishop back now bishop
to a2
you could go to e2 but um uh well
a2 uh is a bit better because the black
king is still in the center of the board
you can see that black is wasting a lot
of moves
on rapid development he's still not
worried about king safety
and you want this bishop to be included
in the fight for the central squares
here on d5 so here we have bishop to b7
and now trying to exploit that the black
king is still in the center of the board
with d5 you want to open up the position
so e captures on the e5
knight captures on the uh sorry knight
captures on d5
and now not knight captures on d5 uh but
rather bishop to e7 if you further trade
it here
captures captures for example then it's
going to be
a little bit tricky for black to develop
for for example bishop
e7 you want a castle white can already
jump in with knight to the e5 and now
you already have some problems you kind
of have to give up the bishop
pair here with captures captures and now
the rook cannot be developed
any normal square you can go rook to b8
because then the
a6 pawn falls uh and even if you trade
for example captures captures it's still
uh
well it's very much playable but uh you
know
white does have the bishop pair so you
might want to avoid this
so instead we have bishop to e7 and now
comes e4 cementing that knight here
and asking black are you maybe
interested in this spawn but it would be
very dangerous to
grab the spawn rook to e1 is coming and
could be
a little bit tricky so here black
castles first but levon still ignores
the e4 pawn and he just plays bishop to
f4 so what do you play here
it's kind of a tricky position you might
have to worry about bishop to c7
attacking the queen then the knight
might come to b6 the knight can
immediately come to b6 a lot of stuff to
consider
and capturing here is just not what you
want to do here if you capture it
doesn't matter that the king moved from
the center of the board rookie one is
still uh
very very strong uh problem is you
cannot defend it with f5 because
this diagonal is still open so just
let's say knight captures wins the game
on the spot you just grab a piece with a
double check
and if you retreat for example knight
back to f6
still not enough uh because again it
loses by force uh we're just going to
play knight captures on e7
with check knight captures and then
queen captures on d8 remove the defender
of the knight
and after either rook captures we're
just gonna pick up this knight on e7 and
we're up a piece completely winning for
white
so adjust c4 sasha says all right we're
just gonna
completely lock this bishop out of the
game you're gonna have to first play
rook to c1 or probably move the queen
first connect
the rooks then place them like rook to
d1 then play bishop to b1
to include this bishop into the game at
some point you're going to push e5 so a
lot of moves to get this bishop back
into the game
rook to e1 now the e4 pawn is defended
and here there is one game uh played in
2020 in the iron float open between
uh shimano and abu satoru that ended in
a draw in that game
rook the c8 was played but here we have
rooked the e8 by sasha and it is now
already as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game
so let's see how levon uh continues here
he starts by developing the queen and
connecting rook so
queen to the queen to d2 now the rook
can be played
the c1 to d1 and then uh slowly but
surely we're gonna introduce the bishop
back into the game uh we have bishop the
c5 by sasha the knight
the bishop no longer needed here you
wanted this on this diagonal here you
might even be able to
you know harass the white king a little
bit uh and now as the bishop moved from
e7
the knight is now only defended by the
queen we just pile up on the knight
bishop to g5 and now uh
here the uh sasha might have thought
that maybe this is a draw offer so he
played bishop back to e7 it is the the
best move i mean you don't want this
ever uh being captured
then you will have to you know that if
bishop captures you're going to have to
ruin your kingside pawn structure so
bishop back to e7
and here maybe sasha thought maybe levon
was just interested in going back then
we go here then we go back then we go
here and
a nice draw by threefold repetition uh
but uh
after like i said after losing that game
to mom and jarov levon was not of a
peaceful mind and he played his
signature move you all know which move
that is that is of course
h4 and now i believe sasha already
knew that this game was going to be uh a
hard fought one
so you have to prepare so h6 he says all
right you either trade here or you go
back with the bishop
you also might sacrifice here you do
grab two very
important pawns for for the price of one
bishop but if you do this for example
captures captures and captures yes you
might
have ideas of bishop g knight g5 then we
capture this knight
remove the defender of the h7 square
then queen h7 check queen f7 checkmate
it's all in the air but after knight to
h7 you can see now how the queen the
bishop and the knight really control uh
these two squares and it's gonna be very
hard for
uh for these knights to uh you know
enter enter the the attack and black
will
very very successfully defend any you
know
any attacks so instead after h6 levon
goes back
bishop to f4 and now comes bishop to c5
now the bishop definitely belongs on c5
there's no more need for for the bishop
to be on e7 now that h6 has been played
and now the question is do you play
knight to c7
and here uh i i don't know how
how it all went down but uh i imagine uh
levon did not uh
you know spend all that much time
considering this because he's just not
that kind of a player he he he likes to
create
uh and this is being offered so that
that's not a move that that
one would play and not only that it's
also a losing move for white
if you go if you go uh hungry for
material here and try to win material
with
uh knight to c7 black just wins here and
it's very interesting how black does it
so
feel free to pause the video and try to
solve this hypothetical situation that
never actually happened
while i give you a couple of seconds how
does black win this
[Music]
uh so uh for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations
on finding uh either of two moves and uh
there are some very interesting ideas
knight captures on e4 is one of them
but even more interesting is rook
captures an e4 and this is such a
such a fine move that uh really shows um
uh shows the the the the intricacies of
the position
the problem now okay if you grab
material there is no other move you can
play
because then you've just you didn't do
anything
so after knight captures on c on a8 the
problem is knight to d4
and this is just amazing look at all of
these pieces in front of the black king
look at the bishop pair
it's absolutely fully operational and
the queen can very easily join the
attack so now
the problem is there really isn't a good
move here uh what do you play
uh for example if we bring back the
knight knight to c7 which does make
sense i mean we've just grabbed the rook
why not
just to go back with the knight and what
can black play here the problem is black
wins by force
knight captures an f3 check g captures
on f3 and now okay
the bishop still defends the queen but
you're not interested in the queen just
rook to d4 and what the what can the
white queen do now we have queen to e3
and now comes queen to d7 and this is
just
uh uh this is just incredible if you
look at this position even if someone
gave this position to you from this
position and not from that position
where where
uh garisha decided to give up uh that
rook and a8
it would still not be all that easy to
calculate the problem here is
white does not have a move let's say you
play bishop to g3 just
try and solidify you know everything
on the king side queen to h3 is coming
and
now there's really nothing the bishop's
pair is still here and
there's no move you can play uh you kind
of want to get the queen away from this
this bishop so let's say you play queen
to e2 now comes the incredible rook the
g4
and that's it that white can just resign
uh you cannot capture the rook if you
capture the rook then just queen to g2
or queen to h1 is checkmate as the
bishop on b7 is helping out with the
attack
and if you don't capture the rook well
then how do you defend against rook
captures on g3 the f
pawn is pinned the f-pawn will not be
able to uh to do anything here so
there is no defense here so this is only
one of the lines that can come
from the position uh that was on the
board where uh where
sasha offered this knight to c7 maneuver
but really really just incredible his
setup very very reminiscent of of
rubinstein's immortal game and
there are so many sacrifices that can
happen here
in the end 11 went with a bishop to c7
it's also an incredibly tricky move with
queen to c8
and now comes knight captures on f6 so
opening up a black's king side
this comes with check g captures on f6
and now
queen to f4 so keeping an eye on the
bishop
but still with a lot of pressure here
but
there's still the question of how do you
start an attack here you don't really
have any pieces here
going after the black king they're still
the rook anyone the bishop here is doing
nothing
so what is what is levon's plan here uh
well
here sasha has to be very precise and
here
uh a move like knight the e5 is is one
that goes a long way
uh but here knight to d4 was played
seems like
it's similar he wants to trade off
pieces and uh
seems like it it gets the job done the
problem is this helps
white develop a bit too much because now
white gets to develop with tempo
knight characters on the e4 bishop
captures in the rook
8 to d1 which would not be possible if
the knight for example landed on e5
instead
uh we have bishop back to c5 uh
bishop to e5 here is again the absolute
best way to try and defend this
for example bishop captures an e5 uh
we're going to play f captures an e5
queen captures on h6 but now the black
queen can enter the game with queen g4
uh defend against any threats along the
g file also you're just threatening to
pick off
this pawn maybe there could be an attack
so white is still better but
you know rook to d6 is coming it's going
to it's going to be a very active
position for white but
maybe black will still survive this
however uh here sasha played bishop to
c5 with the idea of shifting
bishop back over to f8 then you can
defend this and you know seems like
everything is working out
but it's not so once again feel free to
pause the video now in this
non-hypothetical position and win the
game for levon
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on playing uh
either
bishop to b1 or just uh you know going
for for a nice check first with the
queen but
bishop to b1 uh just gets the job done
right away queen to g3 then bishop to b1
is also fine but
we on this channel we don't give checks
if you know
the position it doesn't require one to
be given so here
bishop to b1 and now we see the problem
for black now
this diagonal will open up and this is
going to be huge it's still not
uh clear how exactly but uh it is
happening
rook can also be lifted very nicely okay
for the moment not
but you'll see how he plays it first
bishop to f8 you have to
you have to get a defender into the in
there if queen captures on h6 we're
going to play e5 and then bishop to h7
this is game over
there's no defending this so here bishop
to f8 you have to defend against this
but
now now the e3 square has been uh freed
and now
there can be a nice rook lift so rook
the e3
preparing to bring the rook over to g3
bishop to g7 and now
rook to g3 now threatening queen
captures on h6 because the bishop
is pinned we have king the h8 unpinning
and
now only now e5 and this is where things
get
really interesting i mean things are
already interesting but like i said this
game is just
creation after creation after creation
the problem now is black cannot even
capture the bishop
if you capture the bishop then uh okay
it seems weird because how does white
win this
i mean okay you could go for for queen
to five obviously
but there's even the quicker rook
captures on g7
and this is just this is just awesome
king captures e captures an f6
check and now okay you are attacking the
queen here that's undefended but there's
also just
king h8 and queen captures on h6 you
don't even have to capture the queen
you can just play this and that's it
king the g8 queen captures a queen to g7
will be checkmate
so instead after e5 you have to figure
out how to defend against all of this
queen the e6 was played
but it doesn't help him all that much
now comes bishop to
f5 chasing away the the black queen
and now queen the e7 uh you could argue
that why not
why not just attack white's queen here
it doesn't work because queen to g4
now threatens checkmate uh the only way
to defend it is queen to f6 and now
another nice real cliff rook to d6
attacks the queen
and there is no defense there's nowhere
where the queen can move to keep on uh
defending the the bishop and g7 and if
you try and give up a little bit of
material still does it help just bishop
captures
pawn captures rook captures again the
queen has no squares rook a queen to f7
still guards the bishop
but now comes queen captures and g7 with
check
queen captures and now bishop captures
an e5
winning back the queen and after
captures we deliver
checkmate uh instead of winning back the
queen
so there's also that i mean this is just
uh
incredible so many incredible lines here
uh
i'm only showing you the the most
impressive ones here
so here we have queen to e7 uh avoiding
all of that
but now comes rook to d7 uh the last
rook leaf of the game and it was in this
position on rule 29 that alexander gray
should resign the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so while you could uh
you could try a few things for example
captures here attack the white queen
still it falls to the same idea that
we've just shown if queen to f6 rook d6
and
you know everything repeats or after
rook the d7
queen to f8 can be played but this still
doesn't work
just e captures on f6 and again there's
there's nothing you can play here
uh you could capture this but it doesn't
help the bishop captures on f6
now we play rook captures on f7
yep that that's what kind of a game this
is queen captures on f7
removing the black queen from the
defense of the h6 pawn
queen captures and now after queen to h7
we're just going to capture it with
queen captures on h7 and this will not
be checkmate
so this is one incredible game and this
is only a handful of lines only the most
impressive ones uh that okay
the ones that i uh thought were most
impressive
are the ones that i decided to show you
but it has so many of them and
all it all came down to that one uh move
where
uh sasha allowed uh levon to basically
develop his pieces uh a bit more quickly
uh with tempo here after this uh after
this queen to f4
uh this knight to d4 move with knight to
the e5 you don't
get to play rook d1 with tempo get the
bishop into the game so fast and
this is how these top tier games are
decided you you give him one free move
just just the development of the rook
and that's it your
your entire position just deteriorates
and that's that's it
there's no there's no turning back yeah
after rook
e7 uh resigned and eleven bounces back
very nicely after
losing that game to mamadyarov in the
previous round
so uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i i for one thought it was it
was super impressive so i'm very happy
that i was able to show this to you and
that
you know it might have improved your
sunday at least a little bit
although although let's be real it
improved that a lot uh i would like to
thank derek lee uh happy birthday as
paul uh abjet banerjee sankatolov and
the western carpet cleaning in corporate
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day